on prime crime she says she's having
trouble breathing
she said she was stabbed multiple times
it's the attack on a young girl
that left the nation stunned as the
details became more impaired in our
investigation it's extremely disturbing
is a supernatural force to blame we
think we fear
sometimes it didn't feel like anything
it was like
air and what can happen next may
surprise you
she poses a significant risk of bodily
harm to herself others or to property
[Music]
hey there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile and memorable true
crime cases
you know there are a lot of motives to
kill but this one
is unlike any other with the addresses
your emergency linen transfer
caller on big bend may 31st 2014
waukesha wisconsin a terrifying 9-1-1
phone call
is about to start one of the strangest
crime stories
in modern american history
she appears to be stabbed she appears to
be what yeah
a man named greg steinberg is out
bicycle riding when he discovers a young
girl
bleeding on the side of the road she
says she's having trouble breathing
she said she was stabbed multiple times
the nature of this crime scene was
particularly horrific you know our
victim was stabbed in the arms and the
legs and
many times in the abdomen there were 19
stabbing
motions i mean that the nature of this
crime scene is just
very very violent the victim is payton
lightner
she'd been attacked in the nearby woods
but was able to muster up enough
strength to crawl out
she said she can take shallow breaths
she's alert
and she didn't see who did this or how
it happened i don't know
i don't know if she wants to be talking
i started asking
that's okay payton is rushed to the
hospital where doctors frantically try
to save her life
miraculously despite her extensive
injuries
payton survives she missed
death by millimeters i mean one of the
stab wounds
just barely missed her heart largely she
lived because
those wounds were just shallow enough
that she did not have a heart attack and
die right there on the scene
hours later police apprehend the
assailants the suspects
were located near i-94 where they're
both taken into custody
without incident the identity of the
attackers turned out to be as shocking
as the stabbing itself
two 12-year-old girls morgan geyser
and anissa wire classmates of payton
it's
extremely disturbing as a parent and
as a chief of police the will
to carry out this attack means something
is wildly a myth
that they would engage in that kind of
activity and commit
a really aggressive heinous
crime that just doesn't happen without
there being some
a red flag indicators and b
an explanation for of some type
even more frightening is why the girls
did it
apparently they were influenced by
something they saw online
keeping our children safe is more
challenging
now than in years past the internet can
also be
full of dark and wicked things you sound
like a character or something
a character that is on several different
websites
like a fictional character yes who was
this fictional character
anissa and morgan decide to open up to
detectives
and they say things that no one saw
coming
there's this website called the
creepypasta wiki
it's full of like horror stories that
are meant to
purposely scare you and there is one of
them
called slenderman slenderman
the mysterious and unsettling horror
character depicted as a faceless
elongated figure
with multiple tendrils dressed in a dark
suit
although they're in separate
interrogation rooms both morgan and
anisa provide the same motive
for trying to kill payton or whom they
called bella
he has these proxies or sermons
as people call them and
um morgan said hey anissa
we should be proxy i'm just like okay
how would we do that she said we have to
kill bella
okay okay and do you know why she said
that like why is she
because we had to supposedly
prove ourselves worthy to thunder
how many times do you think he stabbed
her i don't know
it happened very quickly all i heard was
screaming
i said i'm sorry
this had to happen and she was like why
am i
[Music]
according to the girls during a slumber
party they lured payton out to the woods
to play a game
but really intended to murder her they
claim that if they didn't do this for
slender man
he would kill them and their families we
think we feel sometimes okay like when
we were
walking up to where to where we were
going
i saw him out of the corner of my eye on
this side
okay and then from said she
her twin crack when no one was moving so
i think there's no question that slender
man and their belief in slender man
played a role in their decision making
on that day
even the victim was able to say that
during the time she was friends with
morgan morgan was quite
obsessed with slender man i believe at
the time
they did think it's either kill peyton
or our family is going to be killed by
the slender man
in fact after the stabbing the girls
walked about five
hours before they were found where were
they headed
[Music]
that all the creepypastas supposedly
lived in
because she wanted to walk to slender
morgan and anissa aren't like other 12
year olds
morgan would be diagnosed with
schizophrenia and anessa
with delusional disorder and depression
when you put two people together that
have
these you know mental challenges
they can feed off each other and i think
the fact that you had two 12 year olds
who both
had some mental disorders they really
connected and when they're connected
together like that
everything becomes more real is this a
case of mentally ill confused children
who didn't know what they were doing or
rather an excuse
for a meticulous cold premeditated act
after all the girls discussed this
attack on payton
for months beforehand the fact that this
is so
incredibly premeditated over a six month
period of time
makes the whole thing even more shocking
one of the plans
was to actually duct tape her mouth so
she couldn't make any noise and then
stab her at a sleepover
and the reason they didn't do that is
they had skated and been
out that evening and they were tired a
search of geyser's home revealed more
there were internet searches for how to
get away with murder
and what kind of insane am i and then
there was the matter
of what was found in morgan's room the
barbie dolls and the
notebooks and the drawings they're so
dark and they're intense and they're
disturbed there were so many signs
it really looked like what she was
reading about
drawing just sort of a precursor to what
was going to happen
there are parts of morgan and denise's
stories that appear to line up
last thing she said me to to me was
i trusted you and then
she said i hate you saying stuff like
i hate you guys i'll never forgive you
and
i trusted you yet when it came to who's
actually the mastermind and stabber
they pointed the finger at one another
told me we had to
why because she said that he'd kill our
families
so back in december or january morgan um
told you like hey we should be proxies
i think yeah morgan and i were also
debating um who does the deed
at first it was me but like i said i was
too squeamish and said
no you do it morgan
jumped on top of bella and started
stabbing her repeatedly and that's when
i
turned around because i couldn't stand
to see that
and then we said that we were going to
play hide and seek and then
jumped her who stamped her first
i think um and he stopped her first and
then i
continued and then she was like martin
make sure she doesn't escape
and then i was like uh anissa said that
she'd go get help
i didn't have anything to do with the
lying well that was alan
they did blame each other in terms of
their perception of what happened and
how it happened
i think they both were just trying to be
honest
but they were also both quick to say it
wasn't just my fault i didn't do this
part
she did that part when we come back
we're going to take a
further look into the minds of these
girls
it sort of just happened it didn't feel
like anything it was like
air
[Music]
so did you think that you actually had
to kill somebody to do it
yeah like for real okay
back in 2014 12 year olds morgan geyser
and anissa wire admit to police
that they stabbed their classmate peyton
lightner
to appease the fictitious online
character known as slenderman
but is one more responsible for this
than the other
and how exactly should they be punished
morgan and anise's interrogation videos
provided the first glimpse into what
they were thinking
while both accounts were chilling there
were startling differences
morgan was cold morgan seemed
completely unremorseful morgan seemed
quite intelligent and quite manipulative
she seemed to
really understand every single thing
that was happening and had no guilt
whatsoever for what she had done
we were careless i knew this would
happen i knew we'd get in trouble
why do you think it was your sleepover
because it was we were all
we would all be together it was a
flawless plan actually
so she put the knife in your hand i
just continued to
you know what happened didn't you anissa
was a bit different
anissa came off as a 12 year old child
she did express some just a tiny level
of remorse for the decision she had made
the whole time people was screaming
and
so we told her we were gonna get help
but we really weren't we were gonna
rather
let her
pass away you definitely have the
feeling i think listening to those
interviews that
morgan was more responsible that she was
the one that actually did the stabbing
but they both said things that made it
clear that they were in this together
they shared
mental disorder they shared loneliness
they shared
obsession with you know dark scary
things
and it's the combination of the two of
them that created this event
morgan and anisa are charged with
attempted first degree
intentional homicide in 2016 after a
lengthy legal battle making it all the
way to the court of appeals
it's determined both defendants who are
then 14 years old
are to be tried as adults in this case
these two girls committed such a
horrible crime
that the view was they need to be
punished they tried to kill
another 12 year old the problem with
civil court
or juvenile court is that once a child
turns 18
the courts don't have control over that
child anymore and the concern is is that
a 12 year old
at 18 may not be ready to be out on
their own considering
such a violent crime the prosecution of
these two girls for attempted murder
became a national story with many
appalled and in disbelief
over the motive yet there were others
who felt sympathy
the interrogations themselves ignited a
ton of discussion
they don't understand what it means to
be interrogated necessarily they don't
understand
how they say things their body language
what they say can be used against them
and so
i think there's an inherent unfairness
do i believe regardless of my belief
that a parent should have been there
that both of them understood their
rights
i think there's no question that morgan
did morgan is i assume of incredibly
high intellect
she understood every single thing that
was going down that day
anissa it's a bit less clear
um again a child can understand
those rights but i think it's it's not
quite as clear with anissa as it is with
morgan
in 2017 anissa changes the game
she agrees to plead guilty to attempted
second-degree murder
but she wants a trial to determine if
her mental illness
excuses her from being criminally
responsible and ultimately
from winding up behind bars the case
against anissa and morgan was
overwhelming but one thing that was also
as far as they were concerned
overwhelming was the evidence of her
mental disease or defect
the prosecution thought that they had
evidence to establish
that the mental disease or defect did
not
have a huge impact on the
decision-making of anissa and morgan
their position was that anissa didn't
believe some of the
issues regarding slenderman until after
the child had been stabbed
a majority of the jury would end up
agreeing with the defense
and decided that even though this was a
violent planned out crime
anissa shouldn't go to prison instead
they say
she needs treatment so what they did
find is by virtue of a mental illness or
mental defect
she did not have the ability to know
right from wrong
you have to realize it wasn't just one
doctor or two doctors that found
that anisa had a mental health issue
during the time that this crime happened
there was a third doctor
that third doctor was actually a doctor
that was assigned
by the court that very same month morgan
follows suit
she pleads guilty to attempted first
degree intentional homicide
in this agreement prosecutors don't
fight the mental illness question
instead they resolve that she should
remain at a psychiatric health facility
legally she was not held responsible and
that's a good outcome
for somebody who has committed this
crime
how long would morgan and anissa be
committed to an institution
anissa was up first and at her
sentencing we learned new
and eerie details about her from her
family
there were times during her
conversations where
she would look almost blank
she's talked about going to school
and becoming an advocate
for children in her situation there have
been times when
she said i don't know why
i would have done this of course a judge
wants as much
information that's admissible or allowed
to be shown before making a decision of
this gravity
now having said that there's a
distinction in my mind between
this is how she's acting this is how
she's helpful
versus the reality of mental health
needs
and treatment before the judge rendered
his sentence
we heard from anissa herself i do hold
myself accountable for this
and that i will do whatever i have to do
to make sure
that i don't get any sort of delusion or
whatever again i want everybody involved
to know
that i deeply regret everything that
happened that day
i'll do whatever i have to do to make
sure that this doesn't happen
and i know you've heard that before and
you're probably going to hear it again
but it's the truth and i'm sorry
i think those are great words but when
you have any type of mental health
issues there's a difference between
thinking that believing that and saying
that and being willing and able to
actually follow through with mental
health treatment
swear continues to believe that slender
man is real she
also stated that as recently as july
2017
she believed that an evil spirit was
pushing down her on her bed
after the spirit had been let out of a
homemade ouija board
she has continued to be easily
influenced by peers
she has been convinced by another inmate
who is a devil worshiper that her
co-actor
meaning uh miss geyser is possessed
what's best for the community may not be
what's best for a niece of wire
as much as we can sit back and say i
will never do that again
and i think it's sincere i'm not
criticizing her for saying it
we don't know anissa was ordered to
spend the next 25 years in a mental
hospital
you know this judge recognized the
seriousness of this crime
he also made it very clear that but for
the grace of god this child would have
been dead
two months later morgan had her
sentencing to let
ella and her family know i'm sorry
i never meant
this to happen i hope
that she's doing well
it was so interesting to see morgan um
at her sentencing and how
different she appeared than she had when
she was first interrogated
after the stabbing incident she was more
emotional
remorseful now could that have been
manipulation
absolutely but i i took it to be real
sincere
emotion for what she had done she
sounded so childlike
i just feel like her maturity to accept
and handle the consequences was
different
than presented by anissa the
circumstances of the wire case are
different
than they were in this case the biggest
underlying difference
is the long history of delusions
when she saw the slenderman
silhouette she said she recognized that
as
a man who had visited her throughout the
years when she
was three or four she poses a
significant risk of bodily harm to
herself
others or to property the judge
sentenced morgan
to 40 years of institutional care
morgan seemed to take a stronger role
in regards to what went down that day
and the judge may have just recognized
that delineation
along with the lack of remorse that she
had shown
all along at the time of this taping
morgan's lawyers are appealing the case
arguing that she should never have been
tried as an adult peyton lightner has
moved on with her life
with plans to enter into the medical
field but that doesn't mean she's
forgotten what happened
nor won't pay attention to what happens
next
legally both morgan and anisa can now
petition
every six months for conditional release
from the hospital
with the niece's case scheduled to be
heard march
2021 here's the reason why i might
consider
early release number one their behaviors
while they're in the facility
number two their diagnosis and treatment
plan
are they able capable of maintaining a
treatment plan so that if they are
released
early they can be expected
not to commit another crime both morgan
and anisa could
eventually get out keep in mind that the
judge has to make a determination
as to how dangerous each of those
individuals are in the community
one only needs to look back at the
interview particularly the interview of
morgan
anyone who watches that video will never
think it's safe to have this girl out of
a mental health facility
three lives changed forever by one
moment
it's a haunting story for many reasons
and it's one that could have resulted in
something
far worse and with legal developments
still up in the air
it's a story that's still being written
that's all we have for you on prime
crime
leave us your comments on the slender
man stabbing on facebook and twitter
with the hashtag prime crime
as always thank you for joining us and
until next time
be safe
[Music]
you